بقي وزير الدفاع لويد أوستن
في المستشفى يوم الأحد بعد
ما يقرب من أسبوع من
دخوله لأول مرة إلى مركز والتر ريد الطبي
في واشنطن بعد مضاعفات ناجمة
عن عملية جراحية اختيارية، والآن يتعافى أوستن
بشكل جيد وفي حالة معنوية جيدة
وفقًا للسكرتير الصحفي للبنتاغون
ولكن الغضب  تزايدت
حقيقة أن البنتاغون لم
يكشف علنًا عن وجود أوستن في
المستشفى إلا بعد 4 أيام من وصوله لأول مرة
إلى البيت الأبيض،
وفي الوقت نفسه لم يعلم الرئيس بايدن أن
أوستن تم إدخاله إلى المستشفى حتى
يوم الخميس الماضي وعلى الرغم من نائبة أوستن
كاثلين هيكس.  لتولي بعض
واجباته أثناء إجازته في بورتوريكو،
لم تكن تعلم أيضًا أنه تم نقله إلى
المستشفى إلا بعد أيام من
دخوله إلى مستشفى والتر ريد، وهو الآن
السكرتير الصحفي العام للبنتاغون، بات رايدر، الذي قال
لشبكة CNN يوم الأحد إن اقتباس أوستن ليس لديه
خطط للاستقالة.  الحادثة
ويصر البيت الأبيض على أن بايدن لا يزال لديه
ثقة كاملة في الوزير، وقال
مسؤول لشبكة CNN إن الاثنين أجريا
محادثة ودية
مساء السبت أخبر فيها بايدن أوستن أنه
يتطلع إلى عودته إلى
العمل ولكن لا تزال هناك أسئلة
لماذا حاول أوستن وفريقه جاهدين
إبقاء حالته سرية، ويشعر العديد من
مسؤولي البنتاغون الآن
بالإحباط الشديد لأنهم تركوا في
الظلام، ويشعر البعض بالقلق من أن ذلك كان من الممكن أن
يشكل خطراً على الأمن القومي لأن
الرئيس وكبار
القادة العسكريين  بما في ذلك أولئك الموجودين في سلسلة
القيادة لم يكونوا على علم بمكان
وجود أوستن. الآن أصدر أوستن من جانبه
بيانًا ليلة السبت
يشيد فيه باقتباس الموظفين المذهلين في
والتر ريد للرعاية التي تلقاها
وقال إنه يقتبس عن الرجال
ويبحثون  أتطلع إلى العودة إلى العمل
وأقر أيضًا بالمخاوف بشأن
الشفافية وقال اقتباسًا أنا ملتزم
بعمل أفضل ناتاشا برتراند سي إن إن
واشنطن